bien la grèce a subi comme les autres
pays européens de plein fouet la crise
financière et économique de 2008 la
différence avec ses voisins c'est que la
grèce était très entêté beaucoup plus
endetté la dette publics en 2009 atteint
déjà 126 % du pib grec
et puis surtout lorsque le gouvernement
révèle qu'une partie du déficit a été en
fait dissimulé et qu'il s'élève à 15% du
pib ce qui est absolument considérable
record en europe
cette nouvelle fait l'effet d'une bombe
la grèce va annoncer un plan d'austérité
sur tous les européens et le fmi
vole à son secours c'est-à-dire qu'ils
vont lui prêter des sommes colossales
ça va prendre trois plans de sauvetage
successifs
au total il y aura 2 188 milliards
d'euros d'argent public prêté
c'est comme si on avait prêté plus de
2000 milliards d'euros à la france c'est
à dire plus d'un an de richesses
produites plus d'un an de pib
alors quand on prête automatiquement ça
creuse la dette puisque on a emprunté la
dette publique s'envole encore plus
alors qu'en principe l'idée était de la
combattre elle ira jusqu'à plus de 180 %
du pib en 2016 alors en échange de ces
prêts les créanciers exigent des mesures
d'austérité drastiques
les pensions de retraites vont baisser
les salaires des fonctionnaires vont
baisser les effectifs dans les
ministères vont baisser les impôts vont
monter c'est un remède de cheval
côté positif on peut dire clairement qu
elle va mieux déjà la croissance est
revenue le chômage a diminué il faut
dire qu'il a atteint jusqu'à 27% de la
population active c'est à dire que un
actif sur quatre étaient sans emploi
aujourd'hui le chômage est redescendu à
environ 16 % de la population active
il n'y a plus de déficits publics mais
un excédent public c'est absolument
remarquable
je vous rappelle que la france elle
accumule toujours les déficits mais il
ya bien sûr des revers à la médaille
le premier c'est que la grèce a perdu
énormément de sa richesse pendant la
crise elle a perdu un quart de son pib
un quart de la richesse produite chaque
année a fondu et même s'il ya eu un
léger rattrapage on en est toujours dans
ces proportions
et puis il ya un chiffre terrible qui
résume les plaies de la grèce c'est que
huit cent mille personnes ont quitté le
pays pendant cette crise alors on peut
terminer quand même sur une note
nettement plus positive très symbolique
depuis quelques jours sur les marchés la
grèce emprunte pour moins cher c'est à
dire avec un taux inférieur que l'italie
c'est un signe qu'elle va nettement
mieux qu'elle inspire la confiance c'est
encourageant